The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Now, today we are
continuing with this last unit.
Unit 5, continued.
The informal title of this
unit is Dealing With Infinity.
That's really the
extra little piece
that we're putting in to
our discussions of things
like limits and integrals.
To start out with today,
I'd like to recall for you,
L'Hôpital's Rule.
And in keeping with
the spirit here,
we're just going to do the
infinity / infinity case.
I stated this a little
differently last time,
and I want to state
it again today.
Just to make clear
what the hypotheses are
and what the conclusion is.
We start out with,
really, three hypotheses.
Two of them are kind of obvious.
The three hypotheses are
that f(x) tends to infinity,
g(x) tends to
infinity, that's what
it means to be in this
infinity / infinity case.
And then the last assumption
is that f'(x) / g'(x) tends
to a limit, L. And this is
all as x tends to some a.
Some limit a.
And then the conclusion
is that f(x) / g(x) also
tends to L, as x goes to a.
Now, so that's the way it is.
So it's three limits.
But presumably
these are obvious,
and this one is exactly what
we were going to check anyway.
Gives us this one limit.
So that's the statement.
And then the other little
interesting point here,
which is consistent with this
idea of dealing with infinity,
is that a equals plus
or minus infinity
and L equals plus or
minus infinity are OK.
That is, the numbers capital
L, the limit capital L,
and the number a can
also be infinite.
Now in recitation yesterday, you
should have discussed something
about rates of growth,
which follow from what
I said in lecture last
time and also maybe
from some more detailed
discussions that you
had in recitation.
And I'm going to introduce a
notation to compare functions.
Namely, we say that f(x)
is a lot less than g(x)
if-- So this means that the
limit, as it goes to infinity,
this tends to 0.
As x goes to infinity,
this would be.
So this is a notation,
a new notation for us.
f is a lot less than g.
And it's meant to be
read only asymptotically.
It's only in the limit as x goes
to infinity that this happens.
And implicitly here,
I'm always assuming
that these are positive
quantities. f and g are
positive.
What you saw in
recitation was that you
can make a systematic comparison
of all the standard functions
that we know about.
For example, the log
function goes to infinity.
But a lot more slowly
than x to a power.
A lot more slowly then e^x.
A lot more slowly
than, say, e^(x^2).
So this one is slow.
This one is moderate.
And this one is fast.
And this one is very fast.
Going to infinity.
Tends to infinity,
and this is of course
as x goes to infinity.
All of them go to infinity,
but at quite different rates.
And, analogous to
this, and today
we're going to be doing this,
needing to do this quite a bit,
is rates of decay, which are
more or less the opposite
of rates of growth.
So rates of decay are rates
at which things tend to 0.
So the rate of decay, and for
that I'm just going to take
reciprocals of these numbers.
So 1 / ln x tends to 0.
But rather slowly.
It's much bigger than 1 / x^p.
Oh, I didn't mention
that this exponent
p is meant to be positive.
That's a convention that
I'm using without saying.
I should've told you that.
So think x^(1/2), x^1, x^2,
they're all in this sort
of moderate intermediate range.
And then that, in turn, goes to
0 but much more slowly then 1 /
e^x, also known as e^(-x).
And that, in turn, this guy
here goes to 0 incredibly fast.
e^(-x^2).
vanishes really, really fast.
So this is a review
of L'Hôpital's Rule.
What we said last time,
and the application of it,
which is to rates of
growth and tells us
what these rates of growth are.
Today, I want to talk
about improper integrals.
And improper integrals,
we've already
really seen one or two of
them on your exercises.
And we mention them a
little bit, briefly.
I'm just going to
go through them
more carefully and more
systematically now.
And we want to get
just exactly what's
going on with these
rates of decay
and their relationship
with improper integrals.
So I need for you to
understand, on the spectrum
of the range of
functions like this,
which ones are suitable
for integration
as x goes to infinity.
Well, let's start out
with the definition.
The integral from a
to infinity of f(x) dx
is, by definition,
the limit as N
goes to infinity of the
ordinary definite integral
up to some fixed, finite level.
That's the definition.
And there's a word
that we use here,
which is that we
say the integral,
so this is terminology for it,
converges if the limit exists.
And diverges if not.
Well, these are the
key words for today.
So here's the issue that
we're going to be addressing.
Which is whether the
limit exists or not.
In other words, whether the
integral converges or diverges.
These notions have
a geometric analog,
which you should always be
thinking of at the same time
in the back of your head.
I'll draw a picture
of the function.
Here it's starting out at a.
And maybe it's going
down like this.
And it's interpreting
it geometrically.
This would only work
if f is positive.
Then the convergent case is the
case where the area is finite.
So the total area is
finite under this curve.
And the other case is the
total area is infinite.
I claim that both of
these things are possible.
Although this thing
goes on forever,
if you stop it at one
stage, N, then of course
it's a finite number.
But as you go further
and further and further,
there's more and
more and more area.
And there are two possibilities.
Either as you go all the
way out here to infinity,
the total that you get
adds up to a finite total.
Or else, maybe there's
infinitely much.
For instance, if it's a
straight line going across,
there's clearly infinitely
much area underneath.
So we need to do a
bunch of examples.
And that's really our
main job for the day,
and to make sure
that we know exactly
what to expect in all cases.
The first example is the
integral from 0 to infinity
of e^(-kx) dx.
Where k is going to be
some positive number.
Some positive constant.
This is the most fundamental, by
far, of the definite integrals.
Improper integrals.
And in order to handle this,
the thing that I need to do is
to check the integral from
0 up to N, e^(-kx) dx.
And since this is an easy
integral to evaluate,
we're going to do it.
It's -1/k e^(-kx), that's
the antiderivative.
Evaluated at 0 and N. And that,
if I plug in these values,
is -1/k e^(-kN), minus--
and if I evaluate it at 0,
I get a -1/k e^0.
So there's the answer.
And now we have to
think about what
happens as N goes to infinity.
So as N goes to infinity,
what's happening
is the second term
here stays unchanged.
But the first term is e
to some negative power.
And the exponent is
getting larger and larger.
That's because k
is positive here.
You've definitely
got to pay attention.
Even though I'm doing this
with general variables here,
you've got to pay attention
to signs of things.
Because otherwise you'll
always get the wrong answer.
So you have to pay very
close attention here.
So this is, if you like,
e to the minus infinity
in the limit, which is 0.
And so in the limit,
this thing tends to 0.
And this thing is
just equal to 1/k.
And so all told,
the answer is 1/k.
And that's it.
Now we're going to
abbreviate this a little bit.
This thought
process, you're going
to have to go through every
single time you do this.
But after a while you
also get good enough at it
that you can make it a
little bit less cluttered.
So let me show you a shorthand
for this same calculation.
Namely, I write 0 to
infinity e^(-kx) dx.
And that's equal to -1/k
e^(-kx) 0 to infinity.
That was cute.
Not small enough, however.
So, here we are.
We have the same calculation
as we had before.
But now we're thinking,
really, in our minds
that this infinity is some
very, very enormous number.
And we're going to plug it in.
And you can either do
this in your head or not.
You say -1/k e^(-infinity).
Here's where I've used the
fact that k is positive.
Because e to the -k times a
large number is minus infinity.
And then here plus 1/k--
minus -1/k, let write it
the same way I did before.
And that's just equal to 0 +
1/k, which is what we want.
So this is the same calculation,
just slightly abbreviated.
Yeah.
Question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good question.
The question is,
what about the case
when the limit is infinity?
I'm distinguishing
between something existing
and its limit being
infinity here.
Whenever I make a discussion of
limits, I say a finite limit,
or in this case, it works
for infinite limits.
So in other words,
when I say exists,
I mean exists and is finite.
So here, when I say
that it converges and I
say the limit
exists, what I mean
is that it's a finite number.
And so that's indeed
what I said here.
The total area is finite.
And, similarly, over here.
I might add, however,
that there is
another part of this subject.
Which I'm skipping entirely.
Which is a little bit subtle.
Which is the following.
If f changes sign, there
can be some cancellation
and oscillation.
And then sometimes
the limit exists,
but the total area, if you
counted it all positively,
is actually still infinite.
And we're going to
avoid that case.
We're just going to treat
these positive cases.
So don't worry
about that for now.
That's the next
layer of complexity
which we're not
addressing in this class.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question is,
would this be OK on tests.
The answer is, absolutely yes.
I want to encourage
you to do this.
If you can think
about it correctly.
The subtle point
is just, you have
to plug in infinity correctly.
Namely, you have to
realize that this only
works if k is positive.
This is the step where
you're plugging in infinity.
And I'm letting you put
this infinity up here
as an endpoint value.
So in fact that's
exactly the theme.
The theme is dealing
with infinity here.
And I want you to be
able to deal with it.
That's my goal.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so
another question is,
so let's be sure here
when the limit exists,
I say it has to be finite.
That means it's
finite, not infinite.
The limit can be 0.
It can also be -1.
It can be anything.
Doesn't have to be
a positive number.
Other questions.
So we've had our first example.
And now I just want to add one
physical interpretation here.
This is Example 1, if you like.
And this is something that was
on your problem set, remember.
That we talked about the
probability, or the number,
if you like, the
number of particles
on average that decay in
some radioactive substance.
Say, in time between
0 and some capital
T. And then that would be
this integral, 0 to capital
T, some total quantity
times this integral here.
This is the typical kind
of radioactive decay number
that one gets.
Now, in the limit, so this
is some number of particles.
If the substance is
radioactive, then in the limit,
we have this.
Which is equal to the
total number of particles.
And that's something
that's going
to be important for
normalizing and understanding.
How much does the
whole substance,
how many moles do we
have of this stuff.
What is it.
And so this is a number
that is going to come up.
Now, I emphasize that this
notion of T going to infinity
is just an idealization.
We don't really believe that
we're going to wait forever
for this substance to decay.
Nevertheless, as theorists,
we write down this quantity.
And we use it.
All the time.
Furthermore, there's other
good reasons for using it,
and why physicists
accept it immediately.
Even though it's not really
completely physically realistic
ever to let time go very,
very far into the future.
And the reason is, if you
notice this answer here,
look at how much simpler
this number is, 1/k,
than the numbers that I got in
the intermediate stages here.
These are all ugly,
the limits are simple.
And this is a theme
that I've been trying
to emphasize all semester.
Namely, that the
infinitesimal, the things
that you get when you
do differentiation, are
the easier formulas.
The algebraic ones, the
things in the process
of getting to the limit,
are the ugly ones.
These are the easy ones,
these are the hard ones.
So in fact, infinity
is basically easier
than any finite number.
And a lot of appealing
formulas come from those kinds
of calculations.
Another question.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question is,
shouldn't the answer be A?
Well, the answer
turns out to be A/k.
Which means that when you
set up your arithmetic,
and you model this to a
collection of particles.
So you said it should
be A. But that's
because you made an assumption.
Which was that A was the
total number of particles.
But that's just false, right?
This is the total
number of particles.
So therefore, if you
want to set it up,
you want set up so
that this number's
the total number of particles.
And that's how you
set up a model,
is you do all the
calculations and you
see what it's coming out to be.
And that's why you need to
do this kind of calculation.
OK, so.
The main thing is, you shouldn't
make assumptions about models.
You have to follow what
the calculations tell you.
They're not lying.
OK, so now.
We carried this out.
There's one other
example which we talked
about earlier in the class.
And I just wanted
to mention it again.
It's probably the most
famous after this one.
Namely, the integral from
minus infinity to infinity
of e^(-x^2) dx.
Which turns out, amazingly,
to be able to be evaluated.
It turns out to be
the square root of pi.
So this one is also great.
This is the constant
which allows
you to compute all kinds
of things in probability.
So this is a key
number in probability.
It basically is the key
to understanding things
like standard
deviation and basically
any other thing in the
subject of probability.
It's also what's driving
these polls that tell you
within 4% accuracy we
know that people are
going to vote this way or that.
So in order to interpret all
of those kinds of things,
you need to know this number.
And this number
was only calculated
numerically starting in the
1700s or so by people who--
actually, by one guy whose
name was de Moivre, who
was selling his services
to various royalty who
were running lotteries.
In those days they
ran lotteries, too.
And he was able to tell
them what the chances were
of the various games.
And he worked out this number.
He realized that
this was the pattern.
Although he didn't know that
it was the square root of pi,
he knew it to
sufficient accuracy
that he could tell
them the correct answer
to how much money their
lotteries would make.
And of course we do
this nowadays, too.
In all kinds of ways.
Including slightly more legit
businesses like insurance.
So now, I'm going to give
you some more examples.
And the other examples
are much more close
to the edge between
infinite and finite.
This distinction between
convergence and divergence.
And let me just-- Maybe I'll
say one more word about why
we care about this very gross
issue of whether something
is finite or infinite.
When you're talking
about something
like this normal
curve here, there's
an issue of how far
out you have to go
before you can ignore the rest.
So we're going to ignore
what's called the tail here.
Somehow you want to know
that this is negligible.
And you want to know
how negligible it is.
And this is the job
of a mathematician,
is to know what finite
region you have to consider
and which one you're going
to carefully calculate
numerically.
And then the rest,
you're going to have
to take care of by some
theoretical reasoning.
You're going to have to
know that these tails are
small enough that
they don't matter
in your finite calculation.
And so, we care very
much about the tails.
Because they're the only thing
that the machine won't tell us.
So that's the part
that we have to know.
And these tails
are also something
which are discussed all the
time in financial mathematics.
They're very worried
about fat tails.
That is, unlikely events that
nevertheless happen sometimes.
And they get burned fairly
regularly with them.
As they have recently,
with the mortgage scandal.
So, these things
are pretty serious
and they really are spending
a lot of time on them.
Of course, there are lots
of other practical issues
besides just the mathematics.
But you've got to get
the math right, too.
So we're going to now talk
about some borderline cases
for these fat tails.
Just how fat do they have to
be before they become infinite
and overwhelm the central bump.
So we'll save this
for just a second.
And what I'm saving up here
is the borderline case,
which I'm going
to concentrate on,
which is this moderate
rate, which is x to powers.
Here's our next example.
I guess we'll call
this Example 3.
It's the integral from
1 to infinity dx / x.
That's the power p = 1.
And this turns out to
be a borderline case.
So it's worth carrying
out carefully.
Now, again I'm going to do
it by the slower method.
Rather than the
shorthand method.
But ultimately, you can do it by
the short method if you'd like.
I break it up into
an integral that
goes up to some large number,
N. I see that it's the logarithm
function is the antiderivative.
And so what I get is ln N
minus ln 1, which is just 0.
So this is just
log N. In any case,
it tends to infinity
as N. goes to infinity.
So the conclusion is, since
the limit is infinite,
that this thing diverges.
Now, I'm going to do
this systematically now
with all powers p,
to see what happens.
I'll look at the integral.
Sorry, I'm going to
have to start at 1 here.
From 1 to infinity, dx / x^p.
and see what happens with these.
And you'll see that p =
1 is a borderline when
I do this calculation.
This time I'm going to do
the calculation the hard way.
But now you're going to have
to think and pay attention
to see what it is
that I'm doing.
First of all, I'm going to
take the antiderivative.
And this is x^(-p), so it's
- -p + 1 divided by -p + 1.
That's the antiderivative of
the function 1/x^p or x^(-p).
And then I have to evaluate
that at 1 and infinity.
So now, I'll write this down.
But I'm going to be
particularly careful here.
I'll write it down.
It's infinity to the -p
+ 1 over -p + 1 minus,
so I plug in 1 here.
So I get 1/(-p+1).
So this is what I'm getting.
Again, what you should
be thinking here
is this is a very large
number to this power.
Now, there are two cases.
There are two cases.
And they exactly split at p = 1.
When p = 1, this number is 0.
This exponent is 0, and
in fact this expression
doesn't make any sense because
the denominator is also 0.
But for all of the other values,
the denominator makes sense.
But what's going on is
that this is infinite
when this exponent is
infinity to a positive power.
And it's 0 when it's
infinity to a negative power.
So I'm going to say it here,
and you must check this at home.
Because this is
exactly what I'm going
to ask you about on the exam.
This is it.
This type of thing, maybe with
a specific value of p here.
When p < 1, this
thing is infinite.
On the other hand, when
p > 1, this thing is 0.
So when p > 1, this thing is 0.
It's just equal to 0.
And so the answer is 1/(p-1).
Because that's this number.
Minus the quantity 1/(-p+1).
This is a finite number here.
Notice that the answer would be
weird if this thing went away
in the p < 1 case.
Then it would be
a negative number.
It would be a very strange
answer to this question.
So, in fact that's
not what happens.
What happens is that the
answer doesn't make sense.
It's infinite.
So let me just write this
down again, under here.
This is a test in
a particular case.
And here's the conclusion.
Ah.
No, I'm sorry.
I think I was going to write
it over on this board here.
So the conclusion is that the
integral from 1 to infinity dx
/ x^p diverges if p <= 1.
And converges if p > 1.
And in fact, we can
actually evaluate it.
It's equal to 1/(p-1).
It's got a nice,
clean formula even.
Alright, now let me remind you.
So I didn't spell the word
diverges right, did I?
Oh no, that's an r.
I guess that's right.
Diverges if p <= 1.
So really, I needed
both of these arguments,
which are sitting above
it, in order to do it.
Because the second argument
didn't work at all when p = 1
because the formula for the
antiderivative is wrong.
The formula for
the antiderivative
is given by the log
function when p = 1.
So I had to do this
calculation too.
This is the borderline case,
between p > 1 and p < 1.
When p > 1, we got convergence.
We could calculate the integral.
When p < 1, when we got
divergence and we calculated
the integral over there.
And here in the borderline
case, we got a logarithm,
and we also got divergence.
So it failed at the edge.
Now, this takes care
of all the powers.
Now, there are a number
of different things
that one can deduce from this.
And let me carry them out.
So this is more or
less the second thing
that you'll want to do.
And I'm going to emphasize
maybe one aspect of it.
I guess we'll get rid of this.
But it's still the issue
that we're discussing here.
Is whether this
area is fat or thin.
I'll remind you of that.
So here's the next idea.
Something called
limit comparison.
Limit comparison is
what you're going
to use when, instead
of being able actually
to calculate the
number, you don't yet
know what the number is.
But you can make a
comparison to something
whose convergence properties
you already understand.
Now, here's the statement.
If a function, f, is similar
to a function, asymptotically
the same as a function,
g, as x goes to infinity,
I'll remind you what
that means in a second.
Then the integral
starting at some
point out to infinity of
f(x) dx, and the other one,
converge and diverge
at the same time.
So both, either, either-- sorry,
let's try it the other way.
Either, both.
Either both converge,
or both diverge.
They behave exactly
the same way.
In terms of whether
they're infinite or not.
And, let me remind you
what this tilde means.
This thing means that
f(x) / g(x) tends to 1.
So if you have a couple
of functions like that,
then their behavior is the same.
This is more or less obvious.
It's just because
far enough out,
this is for large
a, if you like.
We're not paying any
attention to what happens.
It just has to do with the
tail, and after a while
f(x) and g(x) are
comparable to each other.
So their integrals are
So let's just do a
couple of examples here.
If you take the integral from 0
to infinity dx over the square
root of x^2+10, then I claim
that the square root of x^2+10
resembles the square root
of x^2, which is just x.
So this thing is going
to be like-- So now I'm
going to have to do
one thing to you here.
Which is, I'm going
to change this to 1.
To infinity.
dx/x.
And the reason is that
this x = 0 is extraneous.
Doesn't have anything
to do with what's
going on with this problem.
This guy here, the
piece of it from--
So we're going to ignore the
part integral from 0 to 1 dx /
square root of x^2+10,
which is finite anyway.
And unimportant.
Whereas, unfortunately,
the integral of dx
will have a
singularity at x = 0.
So we can't make the
comparison there.
Anyway, this one is infinite.
So this is divergent.
Using what I knew from before.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: The question is,
why did we switch from 0 to 1?
So I'm going to say a little
bit more about that later.
But let me just make
it a warning here.
Which is that this guy here
is infinite for other reasons.
Unrelated reasons.
The comparison that we are
trying to make is with the tail
as x goes to infinity.
So another way of
saying this is that I
should stick an a here and an
a here and stay away from 0.
So, say a = 1.
If I make these both
1, that would be OK.
If I make them both
2, that would be OK.
100, that would be OK.
So let's leave it
as 100 right now.
And it's acceptable.
I want you to stay away
from the origin here.
Because that's
another bad point.
And just talk about what's
happening with the tail.
So this is a tail, and I also
had a different name for it
up top.
Which is emphasizing this.
Which is limit comparison.
It's only what's happening at
the very end of the picture
that we're interested in.
So again, this is as
x goes to infinity.
That's the limit we're talking
about, the limiting behavior.
And we're trying
not to pay attention
to what's happening
for small values of x.
So to be consistent, if
I'm going to do it up
to 100 I'm ignoring what's
happening up to the first 100
values.
In any case, this guy diverged.
And let me give you
another example.
This one, you could
have computed.
This one you could
have computed, right?
Because it's a square
root of quadratic,
so there's a trig substitution
that evaluates this one.
The advantage of this
limit comparison method
is, it makes no
difference whether you
can compute the thing or not.
You can still decide whether
it's finite or infinite, fairly
easily.
So let me give you
an example of that.
So here we have another example.
We'll take the integral
dx, square root of x^3 + 3.
Let's say, for the
sake of argument.
From 0 to infinity.
Let's leave off, let's make
it 10 to infinity, whatever.
Now this one is
problematic for you.
You're not going to be able
to evaluate it, I promise.
So on the other hand 1 over
the square root of x^3 + 3 is
similar to 1 over the
square root of x^3,
which is 1/x^(3/2).
So this thing is going to
resemble this integral here.
Which is convergent.
According to our rule.
So those are the, more or
less the main ingredients.
Let me just mention one
other integral, which was
the one that we had over here.
This one here.
If you look at this
integral, of course
we can compute it so we
know the area is finite.
But the way that you would
actually carry this out,
if you didn't know
the number and you
wanted to check that this
integral were finite,
then you would make the
following comparison.
This one is not so
difficult. First of all,
you would write it as twice
the integral from 0 to infinity
of e^(-x^2) dx.
This is a new example
here, and we're just
checking for convergence only.
Not evaluation.
And now, I'm going to
make a comparison here,
Rather than a limit, comparison
I'm actually just going
to make an ordinary comparison.
That's because this
thing vanishes so fast.
It's so favorable that
we can only put something
on top of it, we can't get
something underneath it
that exactly balances with it.
In other words, this
wiggle was something
which had the same growth
rate as the function involved.
This thing just vanishes
incredibly fast.
It's great.
It's too good for us,
for this comparison.
So instead what
I'm going to make
is the following comparison.
e^(-x^2) <= e^(-x).
At least for x >= 1.
When x >= 1, then x^2
>= x, and so -x^2 < -x.
And so e^(-x^2)
is less than this.
So this is the
reasoning involved.
And so what we have
here is two pieces.
We have 2, the integral
from 0 to 1, of e^(-x^2).
That's just a finite part.
And then we have
this other part,
which I'm going to replace
with the e^(-x) here.
2 times 1 to infinity e^(-x) dx.
So this is, if you like,
this is ordinary comparison
of integrals.
It's something that we did way
at the beginning of the class.
Or much earlier on, when we
were dealing with integrals.
Which is that if you have
a larger integrand, then
the integral gets larger.
So we've replaced the integral.
We've got the same
integrand on 0 to 1.
And we have a larger
integrand on--
So this one is larger integrand.
And this one we know is finite.
This one is a
convergent integral.
So the whole business
is convergent.
But of course we replaced
it by a much larger thing.
So we're not getting the
right number out of this.
We're just showing
that it converges.
So these are the
main ingredients.
As I say, once the thing gets
really, really fast-decaying,
it's relatively straightforward.
There's lots of room to
show that it converges.
Now, there's one
last item of business
here which I have
to promise you.
Which I promised you, which
had to do with dealing
with this bottom piece here.
So I have to deal
with what happens
when there's a singularity.
This is known as an improper
integral of the second type.
And the idea of these
examples is the following.
You might have
something like this.
Something like this.
Or something like this.
These are typical
sorts of examples.
And before actually
describing what happens,
I just want to mention.
So first of all,
the key point here
is you can just
calculate these things.
And plug in 0 and it works and
you'll get the right answer.
So you'll determine,
you'll figure out,
that it turns out that
this one will converge,
this one will diverge,
and this one will diverge.
That's what will
turn out to happen.
However, I want to warn you
that you can fool yourself.
And so let me give you a
slightly different example.
Let's consider
this integral here.
The integral from
-1 to 1 dx / x^2.
If you carry out this
integral without thinking,
what will happen is, you'll
get the antiderivative,
which is -x^(-1),
evaluated at -1 and 1.
And you plug it in.
And what do you get?
You get -1^(-1) minus,
uh-oh, minus (-1)^(-1).
There's a lot of
-1's in this problem.
OK, so that's -1.
And this one, if
you work it all out,
as I sometimes don't get the
signs right, but this time
I really paid attention.
It's -1, I'm telling
you that's what it is.
So that comes out to be -2.
Now, this is ridiculous.
This function here
looks like this.
It's positive, right?
1/x^2 is positive.
How exactly is it that
the area between -1 and 1
came out to be a
negative number?
That can't be.
There was clearly
something wrong with this.
And this is the kind of thing
that you'll get regularly
if you don't pay attention
to convergence of integrals.
So what's going on here is
actually that this area in here
is infinite.
And this calculation
that I made is nonsense.
So it doesn't work.
This is wrong.
Because it's divergent.
Actually, when you get
to imaginary numbers,
it'll turn out that there's
a way of rescuing it.
But, still, it means something
totally different when
that integral is thought to -2.
So.
What I want you to
do here, so I think
we'll have to finish this
up very briefly next time.
We'll do these
three calculations
and you'll see that these two
guys are divergent and this one
converges.
And we'll do that next time.